hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Harry
Potter events and the medieval period do
you know the tale of godlo the dark
Wizard or the history of early quinlich
how about the very first try and wizard
tournament if you take a moment to look
back at the history of the medieval
Wizarding World you'll find the answer
to all these questions and more so join
me as we track back a few hundred years
and learn a thing or two about Wizards
and witches in the Middle Ages 10th
Century dark wizard good low continuing
the tradition of herpa the fowl godelow
pushed the study of dark magic to its
limits with the Elder Wand under his
control the dark wizard recorded his
discoveries in a book called Magic most
evil through that book later Wizards
would Master many spells and curses that
would be outlawed by the ministry of
magic centuries later
interestingly girdelo considered some
magical topics to Taboo to write about
an uncommon trait for a dark wizard
although he knew a great deal about
horcruxes godelow wouldn't explain how
to create them in his book his
contribution to Magic aided Lord
Voldemort in the Death Eaters during the
20th century he was also directly
connected to Harry Potter since he had
once possessed the Elder Wand the
founding of Hogwarts about a decade
before the turn the first Millennium
four powerful Wizards and witches
gathered in Scotland to open the doors
to a brand new school these four figures
godric Gryffindor Salazar Slytherin
Rowena Ravenclaw and Helga Hufflepuff
would never have believed that their
school would remain a thousand years
later as one of the greatest Wizarding
academies in the world although the
school created some of the greatest
Wizards and witches in history it was
also responsible for educating the most
terrible dog Wizards like Voldemort 11th
century quidditch predecessor early
predecessors of quidditch were captured
in paintings and books around Europe in
Britain one of these a game from Germany
known as shtik stock or stick stock bore
a striking resemblance in it two teams
of broom-mounted wizards flew around a
field trying to score goals by
puncturing a dragon's bladder filled
with air another of these early
predecessors came from Ireland this one
called engines shares a few common
traits but you can clearly see how it
diverges instead of pitting two teams
against each other this game consisted
of a simple racing course which Wizards
individually race through their time was
recorded at the very end of the course
after they successfully threw a ball
through a goal circadogan versus the
wiven of Y although the Muggle world
didn't know about it there was another
member of Sir Arthur's Knights of the
Round Table his name was Circa Dogan and
he was a wound caring member of The
Wizarding Community during his time as a
night godogan faced off against a wyvern
from River Y at first cadogan couldn't
muster the strength needed to defeat the
Beast and was quickly beaten back but in
their second encounter godogan struck a
lucky blow and killed the creature in a
fiery display
Bloody Baron murders Helena Ravenclaw
although he was one of the ghosts that
haunted Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and was a tree the bloody Baron's deeds
in life should have prohibited him from
being around children in the 11th
century when Rowena ravenclaw's daughter
Helena ran away the baron was sent after
her when he caught up with Helena the
baron tried to convince her to come back
together with him of course she refused
and the baron overwhelmed with anger
decided the best course of action was to
kill the woman he loved and that's
exactly what he did with the short knife
the baron murdered Helena In Cold Blood
in the aftermath he was so overwhelmed
with the shame that the baron turned the
blade on himself and took his own life
Sword of Gryffindor sometime during the
11th century godric gryffindor's famous
Ruby adorned sword was crafted by the
goblin named Ragnarok the first the
sword was so spectacular that the
Goblins tried to steal it back from
godric but after a short conflict the
Hogwarts co-founder quickly sent the
Goblins home in defeat Chamber of
Secrets during the century Salazar
Slytherin and his three other
co-founders came to an impasse sutherin
refused to allow half-bloods and
muggleborns to enroll at Hogwarts and
the other three disagreed in the end
sutherin left the school but not without
leaving a gift he crafted the Chamber of
Secrets away from the prying eyes of the
other house leaders and left it with a
basilisk inside to protect the honor of
pure Bloods Malfoy's come to England
during the late 11th century the
Malfoy's voyage to England after
successfully aiding William the
Conqueror during the Battle of Hastings
Draco Malfoy's ancestor at the time a
wizard known to his peers as Armon
fought against Harold godwinson in doing
so he won a nice plot of land for
himself as a reward and he used his
status to rise through society as a pure
blood wizard in 12th century trade-in
Wizarding communities throughout the
12th century The Wizarding community in
Britain continued to evolve during this
time many new businesses formed and
bartering became a weekly or daily event
for everyday Wizards and witches during
this Century the very first glimmer of
capitalism in The Wizarding community
and the dent shopping district of Diagon
Alley can be seen puddlemere United
founded Wizards and witches continued to
refine the game of quidditch and by the
year 1163 the game had become so popular
that League teams were established the
oldest one puddle May United was created
this this year 13th century golden
introduced the golden snidget a
predecessor of the golden snitch was
first introduced in a quidditch match in
this Century instead of a small
Enchanted ball an actual yellow bird
named a snidget was used and instead of
awarding 150 points to the winning team
whoever caught the bird was promised 150
galleons by the end of the game every
spectator in the stands realized that
snidgets made the game much more
thrilling from that day on the birds
were included in every game
International warlocks convention in the
year 1289 a mysterious order of warlocks
convened in the secret meeting even if
you pour over the historical records for
days you won't be able to find much
about this clandestine conference since
warlocks were known to be
battle-hardened Wizards it's likely that
the meeting was called in order to avoid
a new war in the visiting Community or
launch a secret one and try wizard
tournament in the 13th century the very
first try was a tournament between
Hogwarts bobatar and durmstrang was held
since that day the tournament has been
held every five years for over seven
centuries although the games had been
put on hold in the late 18th century
they eventually returned during Harry
Potter's time at Hogwarts in the late
1990s a manticore attack during the
Medieval Era human settlements had
forced many of the magical worlds beasts
and creatures to the fringes this meant
dangerous encounters were at an all-time
low and growing ever rarera but in the
13th century a Savage Manticore attacked
an innocent passerby terrorizingly local
community and pushing the Wizarding
World to its limits in the end the
Manticore was too powerful to capture
and ended up leaving the sight of its
attack out of its own volition 14th
century golden snitch during the 14th
century the golden snitch was finally
introduced in the game of quidditch this
saved the lives of thousands of golden
snidgets the yellow feathered bird which
had been used for centuries prior the
creature had nearly been put into
extinction by its use in the Wizarding
game the golden snitch marked one of the
final changes to the game of quidditch
by the end of the century the only new
additions were rules declaring when and
where you could play the game in order
to avoid detection by Muggles more witch
hunts throughout the 14th century muggle
persecution of witches and wizards
escalated with witch hunts and public
burnings at all-time highs The Wizarding
Community desperately pleaded in secret
with muggle leaders to stop the violence
with only a few royal families
interested in helping Wizards the
magical Community was forced to come up
with a solution themselves so they
created the flame freezing charm which
made the Muggles fascination with
burning which is alive at the stake an
impossible feat to achieve Philosopher's
Stone invented Nicola Flamel was born in
1326 and only a few decades later his
passionate pursuit of alchemy led him to
create the Sorcerer's Stone with this
Stone he was able to produce the elixir
of Life which kept him and his wife
alive for hundreds of years at the time
this was the only successful creation of
the stone which had been the goal of
Alchemists for thousands of years more
Quidditch teams as the golden snitch
made the game of quidditch more
accessible more and more Regional teams
sprouted up the wimborne wasps and many
more joined other established teams like
the pride of poetry and the Kenmare
kestrels with so many swelling teams
sightings by Muggles became more and
more common and so did The Wizarding
courts finds for getting caught and
that's it for this video if you want to
know what happened in the centuries that
followed then please leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live